Bonjour tout le monde. Bienvenue dans un nouveau podcast. On se retrouve
à l'extérieur. Je refilme avec la petite
caméra. Ça faisait un moment que je n'avais pas fait de podcast comme ça avec la petite caméra et ça faisait
longtemps que je n'avais pas parlé de mon apprentissage du japonais mais aussi et surtout du portugais puisque
en octobre l'année dernière, j'avais dit sur cette chaîne que je commençais à apprendre le portugais et j'avais
commencé à faire des vidéos hebdomadaires, donc une vidéo toutes les semaines. Hebdomadaire.
Si je fais une vidéo quotidienne, des vidéos quotidiennes, c'est tous les jours et hebdomadaire, c'est toutes les
semaines et après c'est mensuel ou annuel.
Et donc je faisais une vidéo par semaine pour expliquer mon avancée du portugais et au bout d'un moment, j'ai arrêté.
Donc j'ai arrêté ces mauvais signes pour mon apprentissage. Mais aujourd'hui, je voulais vous donner un
peu plus de détails sur mon apprentissage de ces deux langues. Je pense que c'est intéressant puisque
bah ça parle de l'apprentissage des langues. Bien évidemment, ce n'est pas je ne vais pas parler spécifiquement du
français, mais plus de mon approche de l'apprentissage et de ma propre expérience finalement qui qui est
sûrement très similaire à la vôtre et qui moi m'aide aussi en tant que professeur de français à comprendre
bah les difficultés des étudiants et les besoins qu'ils ont dans leur apprentissage.
Donc pour commencer la je me suis pris des notes pour commencer comment est-ce que j'ai
commencé à apprendre les deux langues?
Donc le point de départ de tout ça, c'est le japonais. C'est que bon à
l'école en France, on apprend deux langues étrangères et en général on fait anglais espagnol. Anglais en première
langue, espagnol en deuxème langue. Et personnellement, j'ai jamais été fantastique en langues étrangères. En
espagnol, j'étais particulièrement mauvais. Et en anglais, bon, je me débrouillais parce que j'avais la
chance de souvent voyager notamment en Écosse. On avait des amis Écossais et du coup, j'allais souvent en Écosse chez
eux l'été. Donc j'avais beaucoup d'opportunités pour pratiquer et j'étais j'aimais beaucoup tout ce qui était la
culture américaine, le skate, le rock and roll des années 2000, linkin park, tout ça. Donc finalement, j'avais un pied
dans la dans la avec enfin dans la j'allais dire dans la culture anglaise mais dans la culture anglophone assez
facilement. Et donc ça pour ça, je pense que c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
pu j'ai pu avoir un niveau en anglais correct, même si ça a pris
beaucoup de temps et même si je n'avais pas particulièrement envie d'apprendre des langues à l'école. Et du coup,
comment est-ce que enfin pourquoi est-ce que je me suis retrouvé à apprendre le japonais? La raison est assez simple.
Depuis jeune, depuis que j'ai 10 11 ans, je pense, je lis des mangas. Je regarde
des animés, bon, pas de manière très intensive, mais j'ai toujours aimé ça.
Et pour avec ma femme, pour notre premier grand voyage, on hésitait entre plusieurs destinations. Et moi, il y
avait deux pays que que je voulais voir, c'était le Canada ou le Japon. Et
finalement, on s'est dit pourquoi pas le Japon en sachant que ma femme avait rencontré une amie japonaise dans un
stage linguistique, donc un stage pour apprendre l'anglais en Angleterre. Et c'est un peu ce qui nous a fait aussi
choisir le Japon parce qu'on s'est dit bah on va pouvoir voir Mariko à Tokyo,
notre ami Mariko à Tokyo. Et donc là c'est la raison enfin c'est pour ça
qu'on est allé pour la première fois au Japon en 2020 en fin janvier 2020 donc
juste avant le Covid et pendant ce voyage ben on est tombé amoureux du pays
et en rentrant on a commencé à apprendre le japonais.
On a commencé sans forcément avoir de grandes ambitions et je pense que pendant 1 an,
on faisait un cours de japonais par semaine, un cours de 1h 1h30 je crois à
dans une école à Paris, l'Institut japonais à Paris.
Et et ben c'est un peu comme ça que je suis tombé dans l'apprentissage des
langues. C'est-à-dire que j'ai commencé à apprendre comme ça à l'Institut de Paris 1h30 par semaine et petit à petit
je me suis dit bon ça a quand même l'air compliqué cette histoire et j'ai pas
l'impression qu'en passant 1 heure et demi par semaine je vais progresser assez vite pour avoir un niveau correct
assez vite. Et à partir de ce moment-là, en fait, j'ai commencé à regarder des
des vidéos des vidéos surtout sur YouTube de personnes qui expliquent comment elles apprennent le japonais. Et
là tout de suite, c'était les systèmes de flashcard, Anki, faire de l'immersion et cetera, tous les concepts
un peu généraux de l'apprentissage des langues. Et j'ai découvert ça et je suis un peu tombé amoureux de ça
puisque à partir de ce moment-là, j'ai commencé à apprendre le japonais sérieusement et je continue encore. Donc
ça c'était un an après notre voyage, je pense que j'ai commencé à vraiment apprendre le japonais.
Je sais pas si vous entendez l'avion, mais du coup voilà, 1 an après, donc en
début 2021, on va dire, j'ai commencé à vraiment sérieusement apprendre le japonais et je crois qu'à l'époque,
j'avais un streak, donc un nombre de jours consécutifs qui démarrait début 2021. Et du coup, à ce moment-là,
j'ai vraiment adoré. Je suis tombé dedans. À ce moment-là, je travaillais dans un travail de bureau à
Paris. J'étais data analyste en gros. Et et à côté de ça, je continuais
d'apprendre le japonais. Avec ma femme, on avait pour projet de partir 1 an au
Japon et pourquoi pas vivre au Japon. Et c'est la raison, une des raisons pour
laquelle j'ai continué à apprendre.
Et ensuite, on est parti au Japon 1 an, on est revenu et moi à ce moment-là,
j'ai décidé de changer de métier. Enfin, on était 1 an au Japon et en fait, on se
posait la question est-ce qu'on veut rester plus longtemps ici? Et en fait, on s'est dit bah qu'on aimerait
bien changer de travail et que c'était peut-être mieux de rentrer en France pour changer de travail, quitte à
revenir plus tard au Japon. Et c'est ce qu'on a fait. Du coup, on est rentré,
moi je suis devenu professeur de français. J'ai commencé cette chaîne YouTube et et j'ai commencé à donner
des cours de français.
Après ça, du coup, j'ai commencé à aussi vouloir apprendre le portugais tout simplement parce que je suis moitié
portugais. Alors, ma mère est née en France, mais mes grands-parents étaient portugais et une bonne partie de ma
famille maternelle, donc la famille de ma mère est encore au Portugal. Et c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu apprendre le
portugais. D'autant qu'à ce moment-là, je me disais bah j'apprends le japonais, j'ai un niveau je
commence à avoir un niveau bien intermédiaire.
Le japonais, c'est très difficile. Donc je me suis dit je vais apprendre le
portugais assez facilement et ça va être vite expédié entre guillemets. Je vais vite avoir terminé avec le
portugais.
Et c'est pour ça qu'en en octobre, je crois que c'était en octobre, j'ai fait
des vidéos où je disais "Je me donne 3 mois pour apprendre le portugais pour
pouvoir parler avec ma famille."
Et bon, le fait est que je n'ai pas réussi pour plusieurs raisons, mais
du coup même si je n'ai pas réussi ce défi entre guillemets d'apprendre en 3
mois, je continue d'apprendre le portugais parce que j'ai toujours envie de savoir parler portugais.
Je pense je n'ai pas réussi pour plusieurs raisons, mais je pense que le la raison numéro 1, c'est que je n'ai
pas consacré assez de temps à l'apprentissage du portugais. Je le répète souvent, mais apprendre une
langue, ça demande avant tout, ça demande beaucoup de temps. C'est-à-dire que avant de se demander si on est doué
pour ça ou pas, il faut juste savoir est-ce qu'on a envie de passer du temps
à apprendre une langue? J'ai plutôt envie de dire que oui, ça vaut le coup,
qu'il ne faut pas trop se mettre la pression au début, mais dans tous les
cas, il faut accepter que ça prenne du temps. Et ça, je pense que c'est mon
problème principal actuellement sur l'apprentissage de ces deux langues, c'est le temps. Le temps tout simplement
parce que déjà je donne des cours de français, donc je travaille, je suis en
train de créer un peu une plateforme, donc ça ça me demande du temps aussi. On
a les conventions avec ma femme. Donc on est allé en Belgique, en Allemagne. Là
on est à Paris. On va en faire une à Paris. Ça demande beaucoup de temps le
weekend notamment. Et j'ai deux langues à apprendre. Donc j'ai le japonais et le portugais.
Et ça du coup c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pour l'instant ce qui me freine un peu dans cet apprentissage. Enfin ce
qui me freine c'est plutôt ce qui explique pourquoi je progresse pas plus vite, c'est que je ne passe pas assez de
temps à apprendre. Et dans une vidéo précédente, je disais qu'il faut être en accord avec soi-même. Il faut être
d'accord avec le fait d'apprendre plus ou moins lentement. Et là actuellement, je suis tout à fait en accord avec le
fait que je ne progresse pas très vite.
Ce qui est assez marrant, c'est que c'est que quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le portugais, en fait, ça m'a
remotivé à apprendre le japonais. Et du coup, quand j'ai commencé le portugais, très rapidement, j'ai passé beaucoup
plus de temps à apprendre le japonais.
Et là récemment, c'est un peu l'inverse.
C'est-à-dire que je me suis dit bon, j'ai envie de passer plus de temps sur
le portugais parce que je me dis bon, j'apprends le portugais à un niveau B1
voire B2 max et comme ça c'est fait, je peux parler avec des Portugais pas de
manière parfaite. Désolé, il y avait quelqu'un dans la maison, je suis juste allé voir qui c'était. Mais je disais
que là récemment, c'est plutôt l'inverse, c'est que je me suis dit, j'ai envie d'avoir un bon niveau en
portugais comme ça après je me mets moins la pression par rapport à ça
et je peux passer plus de temps à apprendre le japonais. En sachant que le
portugais, je me dis bon, je pourrais continuer d'apprendre en lisant des livres ou en écoutant des podcasts
mais sans être autant concentré dessus.
Et du coup voilà, actuellement je passe plus de temps sur mon portugais. Mon objectif c'est bah c'est d'avoir un
niveau correct en portugais et c'est aussi de d'avoir un bon niveau en japonais. Ça c'est vraiment mon objectif
numéro 1. Mais la réalité c'est que le japonais c'est vraiment dur. Et en fait,
je me demande, je me suis posé la question plusieurs fois, pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi dur pour un
un européen, un français ou enfin un occidental ou enfin une personne qui a une langue maternelle latine ou
anglo-saxone, on va dire.
Et je pense qu'il y a plusieurs raisons à ça.
La première raison, c'est la structure.
C'est que le japonais, ça suit une structure attendez s o v donc sujet, objet verbe
alors que nos langues latines ou l'anglais par exemple c'est s v o sujet, verbe, objet. En anglais, vous allez
dire I eat an apple. En français, vous allez dire je mange une pomme. Et en
fait, en japonais, vous allez dire 私はリンゴを食べる, vous allez dire I an apple it. Quand je donne cet exemple, on
peut se dire "Bon d'accord, bon c'est pas c'est pas sorcier entre guillemets.
C'est pas sorcier, ça veut dire c'est pas compliqué. C'est une expression pour dire "Oh, ça va, ce n'est pas trop
compliqué."
Sauf que ça, c'est la forme d'une phrase la plus basique possible. Et en fait ce
qu'il faut s'imaginer c'est que du coup tout est comme ça, tout est inversé, tout est la structure des phrases est
complètement différente. Et je m'en suis rendu compte aussi en regardant des animés. En fait, comme maintenant je
comprends le japonais, je comprends plus le japonais. Quand je regarde des animés avec les sous-titres en français,
je me rends compte qu'en fait ce que le personnage dit et ce que les sous-titres
français affichent, ce n'est pas du tout la même chose. Tout simplement parce que si le personnage dit une phrase plutôt
longue, en japonais, il va commencer par dire enfin, il va faire le début de la
phrase, mais en français, on va commencer par dire la fin. Je sais pas si je je vais prendre le
risque de donner un exemple, mais en fait comme vous avez le verbe à la fin,
nous on commence par le verbe et du coup on va dire "Ah, j'ai mangé une pomme
avec ça là-bas et c'était comme ça et cetera." Et en fait en japonais, vous
allez dire "Ah ça là-bas avec lui et cetera, j'ai mangé une pomme." Et enfin,
j'ai une pomme, j'ai mangé. Et en fait les informations, elles sont complètement inversées, ce qui fait que
c'est très difficile, enfin c'est impossible d'avoir une traduction directe. Et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
je pense que les services comme Google traduction sont moins fiables sur avec le japonais qu'avec
l'espagnol par exemple. Bon, c'est des services qui sont fiables. C'est-à-dire que la traduction un japonais va la
comprendre, mais souvent quand on montre une traduction automatique, un japonais, il va dire "Ah ouais, oui, je comprends
mais c'est un peu bizarre, c'est pas très naturel ou c'est trop formel et cetera."
Et donc ça la structure c'est vraiment je me rends compte à quel point ça c'est
une difficulté parce que notre cerveau il est pas du tout habitué et du coup
c'est vraiment un nouveau système à apprendre et pour ça c'est très difficile. La deuxième chose, c'est que
il n'y a aucun mot qui ressemble au français. Et ça, je le vois en
portugais, c'est que en portugais, tous les mots quasiment ressemblent au français. Et c'est pareil
en anglais en soit. En anglais, vous avez beaucoup de mots qui ressemblent au français et c'est un énorme avantage
pour apprendre le vocabulaire parce que au début quand on apprend le japonais, bah tout sonne pareil. On ne fait
pas la différence entre les mots et comme on nous dit ce mot ça veut dire
ça. On a aucun repère. On a rien pour l'enregistrer en fait. On a
rien pour le raccrocher. La mémoire notre cerveau, il aime bien raccrocher des informations à des informations qui
existent déjà dans notre cerveau. C'est pour ça que par exemple on va utiliser des moyens pardon mémotechniques.
On va créer une histoire à partir de choses qu'on connaît déjà pour intégrer une nouvelle information. Et ça du coup
avec le japonais c'est hyper difficile tout simplement parce que tout est nouveau. Et souvent on dit ce qui
est difficile dans le japonais c'est les caractères. Donc c'est les signes, l'alphabet japonais. Et en fait oui,
c'est difficile parce qu'il y en a énormément à apprendre mais d'un autre côté c'est aussi plus facile ensuite
pour apprendre. Tout simplement parce que le fonctionnement après c'est comme un puzzle quand vous connaissez les
caractères. Après, c'est un puzzle. Je prends souvent cet exemple, mais par exemple en japonais, vous allez avoir le
caractère de la montagne et le caractère du feu. Et du coup, si vous connaissez
ces caractères, après quand vous mettez montagne et feu ensemble, ça vous fait un nouveau mot et vous avez appris le
mot volcan. Alors, quand en français, si je vous dis montagne feu, bah si vous ne
connaissez pas le mot volcan, vous ne pouvez pas le deviner. Donc ça, je pense
que c'est un avantage du japonais qui rend la langue plus facile.
En français, vous allez avoir ça par exemple avec par exemple si vous mettez "-de"
avant un mot, ça veut dire l'inverse. On va dire faire to do, défaire to undo. En anglais, ça va être
un unfinished, unreal, je sais pas. Mais bon, en français, ça va être un peu la même
chose. Donc vous avez un peu ce système mais dans une proportion beaucoup moins grande et pour ça le japonais est plus
simple. Mais du coup, je pense que quand j'ai quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le japonais, tout le monde
dans la communauté d'apprentissage japonais, tout le monde dit faites de l'immersion, faites de l'immersion,
faites de l'immersion. Et ça, je pense que c'est d'autant plus vrai que comme c'est une langue totalement différente,
il y a pas beaucoup d'autres solutions que de faire de l'immersion. Tout simplement parce que notre cerveau doit
s'habituer à cette nouvelle structure de phrase à ces mots de vocabulaire qui sonnent complètement différemment et ça
il faut obligatoirement passer par là.
C'est un peu comme s'il fallait faire un reset du cerveau pour qu'il fonctionne dans un autre système, faire une sorte
de mise à jour pour qu'il fonctionne dans un autre système. Et du coup pour
ça l'immersion c'est vraiment hyper hyper important.
Et c'est un peu particulier parce que quand j'ai commencé à apprendre le
portugais, du coup je me suis dit mais en fait il faut que je fasse un
maximum d'immersion et j'ai commencé à essayer de faire un maximum d'immersion et c'était un peu troublant parce que
j'avais l'impression de comprendre assez facilement, de comprendre presque même des contenus natifs alors que je commençais à peine à
apprendre.
Le point positif, c'est que j'avais l'habitude de quand quand je parle de la lecture pour
apprendre de l'immersion et cetera, le point important, c'est d'être de ne pas chercher à tout comprendre à 100 % mais
d'essayer d'avoir un peu le le fil rouge de l'histoire, c'est-à-dire comprendre le ce que ce qui se passe dans
l'histoire, le sujet de la vidéo et cetera. Et ça du coup en portugais, j'avais un peu cette démarche de me dire
"Bon, je ne comprends pas tout mais je vois à peu près ce qu'ils disent." Et ça
et ça c'était un peu bizarre parce que du coup très vite je suis arrivé à cette
frustration qui est le fameux "Je comprends mais je ne peux pas parler".
Le "Je comprends mais je ne peux pas parler". C'est très frustrant parce que parce qu'on a l'impression de connaître
la langue mais ensuite on ne peut pas l'utiliser. Et en fait récemment, j'ai commencé à adopter enfin non pas
récemment, au début j'ai commencé à faire un peu de conjugaison et récemment j'ai commencé à faire un peu plus de
grammaire aussi pas vraiment de la grammaire comme on l'entend. Je lui ai pas demandé de m'apprendre des phrases
toutes faites, mais j'ai j'ai demandé à l'intelligence artificielle, donc à Claude en l'occurrence, j'ai demandé de
me donner des phrases à traduire pour me faire travailler différents points de grammaire. Et en fait, quand
j'ai commencé à faire ça, je me suis rendu compte que bah je ne connaissais
pas grand-chose du portugais finalement.
Je ne connaissais pas vraiment son fonctionnement.
La première chose, bien évidemment, c'est la conjugaison. C'est-à-dire que il y a des formes de verbe et si je ne
sais pas les utiliser, ben forcément, je ne vais pas pouvoir parler. Mais même au-delà de ça, il y a des formes de
phrases. Par exemple, il y a beaucoup de verbes qui utilisent un article après. En français,
on va dire "Je pense à quelque chose."
"Je pense à". Si vous dites "Je pense de quelque chose", ce n'est pas correct. Et
et ça, je me suis rendu compte bah du coup en portugais, je ne le
connaissais pas du tout. Et en fait, j'ai commencé à à faire ça. Et au fur et
à mesure que j'ai commencé à avoir une approche un peu plus théorique, j'ai commencé à me demander si
l'immersion n'était pas suffisante justement pour le portugais. Est-ce que ce n'est pas suffisant de juste écouter
et juste regarder des podcasts ou des vidéos comme ce que vous êtes en train
de voir?
Et en fait je pense que le piège je pense que le piège des langues qui
sont ressemblantes à notre propre langue maternelle quand on fait de l'immersion, c'est d'avoir l'impression de
comprendre. Je je m'explique. On peut comprendre quelque chose de manière générale, mais ça ne doit pas nous
empêcher d'essayer de tout comprendre.
C'est un peu contradictoire avec ce que j'ai dit avant. Mais ce que je veux
dire, c'est que quand on fait de l'immersion, il faut toujours essayer de faire un effort. C'est-à-dire que si on
comprend le sujet global de la vidéo, on va se poser la question est-ce que je
comprends toutes les structures qu'il y a? Est-ce que je comprends les conjugaisons des verbes par exemple? Et
ça, je pense que c'est un peu contreintuitif parce que quand on écoute et qu'on a l'impression de comprendre,
ben on se dit "Bah c'est bon", on se dit pas je maîtrise
mais on se dit "Bon, c'est bon, je comprends donc je n'ai pas besoin de me
concentrer davantage."
Et en fait, je pense que c'est un piège dans lequel je suis tombé, c'est d'être
presque un peu fainéant et de juste écouter, faire de l'immersion de manière un peu passive et finalement bah que
je ne m'améliore pas vraiment en portugais.
directement à parler avec quelqu'un en portugais. Donc il y a en fait un je sais pas si cette personne je sais
pas si ... il s'appelle Béné, je sais pas si Béné regarde ces vidéos mais en tout cas il m'a contacté sur
Instagram pour qu'on fasse des appels en portugais et en français. Et en fait quand je me suis dit bon il faut que je
commence parce que j'ai l'impression de stagner et mon objectif c'est quand même de pouvoir parler en portugais. Donc je
vais essayer et on va voir. Et en fait très rapidement je me suis rendu compte
que voilà je manquais un peu de de théorie et que ça me freinait parce que
d'un côté je manquais de cette théorie et de l'autre quand je faisais de l'immersion je n'avais pas l'impression
de manquer de cette théorie tout simplement parce que j'avais une approche plus passive on va dire.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est que pour le japonais, ça ne m'a pas du tout fait
ça. Tout simplement parce que le japonais, je ne peux pas à peu près comprendre. C'est soit je comprends,
soit je ne comprends pas du tout. Tout simplement parce que les mots, ils ne
ressemblent pas au français. Et ça, je pense que c'est un peu le faux ... un
piège, une fausse impression qu'on peut avoir quand on apprend une langue qui est similaire à la nôtre. C'est un peu
d'avoir cette idée de se dire bon ben c'est bon, je comprends. Alors qu'en fait on ne comprend pas vraiment. Et ça
quand c'est une langue difficile comme le japonais, le mandarin, le coréen par exemple, bah on peut pas tricher.
C'est-à-dire que si vous ne comprenez pas, bah vous ne comprenez pas du tout.
Et et donc ça, je pense que c'est un peu la différence entre ces deux langues et
c'est ce dont je me suis rendu compte récemment, c'est que finalement cette approche 100 % immersion, ce truc de ce
discours où des fois on dit la grammaire c'est nul et cetera, bah je suis un peu
en train de faire machine arrière, de prendre un peu de recul pour me dire que
finalement ce n'est pas si mal de passer un peu par la théorie parce que
juste l'immersion, si on n'est pas pleinement concentré, on peut avoir une fausse impression. Et du coup
maintenant, j'ai plus cette approche avec le portugais. J'ai plus cette approche de me dire "Bon, OK, demain si
j'ai envie de parler, qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de dire?" Et je fais ça, quand
j'ai l'appel avec la personne avec qui je parle en portugais. Mais du coup, ça me force en
fait à me poser la question "Mais est-ce que je sais dire je peux manger
quelque chose par exemple?" C'est tout bête hein, mais et en fait là tout de
suite ça va poser les questions un peu plus théoriques de dire "Non, ce verbe,
ça s'utilise comme ça." je pense que au portugais, on va dire "eu acho que" et
du coup là, j'apprends plus le bloc et j'ai une approche peut-être plus théorique que juste écouter et après
parler. Mais ça me permet d'améliorer mon portugais tout
simplement.
Donc voilà, c'était plus mon point c'était plus là-dessus. C'était que finalement l'apprentissage des langues,
c'est assez unique d'une langue à l'autre et qu'il ne faut pas si vous sentez que vous stagnez, il ne faut pas
hésiter à essayer des choses un peu différentes. Si vous avez l'impression de comprendre facilement
toutes ces vidéos, essayez de vous demander est-ce que est-ce que je peux faire autre chose pour soit aller sur du
contenu plus difficile, soit pour mon expression essayer de dire des choses différentes et pour ça va être choisir
des sujets qui vous intéressent, choisir des sujets sur lesquels vous avez envie de parler et si Vous si vous n'avez pas
quelqu'un avec qui parler, vous pouvez vous imaginer faire une interview
en français où un français vous demande
"Mais qu'est-ce que tu penses de quelque chose?" Et il faut que ce soit
un sujet qui vous intéresse à tout prix.
Si vous êtes américain, le plus facile, c'est imaginer un français qui vous dit "Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de Donald
Trump Ça peut être positif comme négatif, hein. Ce n'est pas mon problème. Mais déjà, c'est une
question qui est très qui est très probable en France si vous êtes
américain.
Et et donc soit enfin, il y a de grandes chances pour que vous soyez
intéressé par la politique et il y a de grandes chances pour que ce sujet vous
intéresse. Et donc à partir de ce moment-là, ça va vous permettre de vous de parler d'un sujet qui vous
intéresse. Et ça c'est hyper important parce que si vous ne vous projetez pas dans ce que vous allez dire, ça ne va
pas marcher. Et je me rends compte avec le portugais où au début j'essayais de
dire un peu des phrases bateau et là quand je notamment aujourd'hui avant mon appel
avec Béné, avec la personne avec qui je parle portugais, j'ai préparé quelques points et j'avais envie de vraiment les dire et
sûrement que j'ai dit n'importe comment, mais au moins ça m'a permis de vraiment avoir envie et de m'exprimer et ensuite
à partir de ça, je vois ce que je ne comprends pas pour travailler et pour
après dans l'immersion aussi essayer de repérer les choses que je ne comprends pas à 100 %.
Donc voilà, c'était une vidéo vraiment quasiment sans script. C'était peut-être
moins organisé, moins structuré que les vidéos précédentes, plus à l'ancienne, enfin plus comme les vidéos il y a
quelques mois. J'espère que ça vous aura plu. Si jamais, n'hésitez pas à mettre un
j'aime et un commentaire pour me
soutenir. Vous aurez les trois PDF sur Patreon pour les membres Patreon et vous aurez le script accessible gratuitement
également sur Patreon. Voilà, merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo jusqu'au bout et je vous dis à la prochaine.